I think more importantly for us is
actually about the EV transition because
EVS today
the the uptake is is happening but they
are luxury item
[Music]
so we've had a lot of talk over the last
few days about the economy
um you have a very interesting lens into
the economy through the Rideshare
business and the eats business can you
give a sense of starting with the US
what are you seeing actually happening
with consumer Behavior
so the consumer from our standpoint
remains quite strong
now the lens with which we're observing
consumer spending is obviously spent on
Mobility spend on delivery food
groceries Etc and I think that one of
the Tailwinds that we are experiencing
is because of uh the the the
switch from spend on retail that was
happening when everyone was at home and
going crazy and just boarding a bunch of
stuff back to spend on Services as the
world is reopening people are going out
again they're going to see friends
families Etc I'd argue that's a little
more healthy spent but we can have a
debate about that or not
and as a result of that shift back to
Services spend
the growth in our business and what we
are seeing in terms of consumer span on
a local basis is actually quite strong
so we we will announce our Q4 earnings
but the range of bookings growth that we
guided to was 23 to 27 that's quite
robust uh and that spend is strong both
of mobility and delivery so it's not in
in one segment uh or the other we've
been obviously because of all the
Prophecies of Doom coming up Etc taking
a very careful look in terms of our best
business can we segment it one way or
the other one of the areas that we've
been focused on is the effect of
inflation on the business and and the
and the fact is twofold one is we're
seeing our restaurant Partners now pass
through increases in their costs service
costs food costs Etc so menu inflation
is up about eight or nine percent and
that does have an effect on unit volume
right the classic economics uh classic
economics apply which is unit volume
then then is a bit slower so for example
unit volume in our delivery businesses
in the single digits decent but single
digits Mobility business it's it's
double digits the other factor and the
people ordering like cheaper dishes and
less sided dishes
we were looking for trade down Behavior
one way or the other uh but it's
resulting in just average basket sizes
being up and unit volume not growing
quite as robustly again single digits
which is fine versus the mobility
businesses which is growing in the very
very solid double digits the other
factor that we're seeing as it relates
to inflation is that about 80 percent of
earners who are coming onto the platform
they're about five million people
earning on Uber on a global basis eighty
percent of those who are signing up are
saying that inflation cost of living had
something to do with their decision to
sign up pay for their groceries pay for
their expenses Etc so in that way our
being a platform that can take a little
bit of a shock right that uh real folks
are experiencing in terms of inflation
that makes the platform more attractive
and to some extent that's a service that
we are serving in terms of society and
are you seeing just quickly using the
same in Europe is quickly mean go faster
no I don't mean that you would you have
verbose at all I thought it was a very
interesting answer I'm all um I don't
spend too long on the economy I want to
get into the business stuff
Europe is that the same picture very
similar learner the picture in Europe
looks quite similar business is strong
uh same thing in Latin America so I
think the shift from retail to uh to
Services is pretty consistent I think
your headline or headline that I read
was that retail spend you know look
pretty weak we recently and again I
wouldn't necessarily take long-term
trends out of that because we made the
mistake during the pandemic of thinking
that the retail boom was you know
long-term Trend turned out that uh you
know everything kind of returns to Norm
so I do think that later in the second
half of the year the world should
modulate off of a very very high base
right as service suspend returns to
normal and then we'll see what happens
given the the lack of experience you
don't really know to what extent this is
just resilience of your business versus
what the economy is doing
I've seen you know many many times CEOs
have made predictions based on
short-term Trends and declare them as
long-term trends reversion to Norm is a
very very powerful powerful force right
um so you wrote a memo in May about
being hardcore on costs and seeing
hiring as a privilege and pushing for
profitability
um can you talk just very quickly about
the impact of that on the business I
mean how is that sort of galvanized
people
um and then I've got a follow-up so
absolutely we we were pretty early in
making that call thank God in in
hindsight
I saw things changing and you know in
business the biggest mistakes that I see
Executives make is
when they don't know what the definition
of good is they think they're doing a
good job
but they actually you know they're
aiming for a Target but it's the wrong
target
right and the reason that I wrote that
memo was because I started seeing what
we're seeing right now which is interest
rates coming up Capital being pulled out
of the market and performance that was
defined as excellent in the past
lots of growth who cares about profit is
performance that is uh described as not
good enough for middling in our new
world yep so I didn't want to and you
know we're a big organization we
organize behind plans lots of people
working their asses off to to get to
those plans and so the reason why I
wrote the memo was you know just like
any company we had annual plans in place
and quarterly targets Etc and everyone
is kind of gunning hard for these
targets and I felt like our definition
of good in terms of performance in terms
of what our own plans were were no
longer good enough and that we had to be
much tougher on costs uh and we had to
achieve the same growth plans with a lot
less investment because the world was
changing invest their expectations were
chatting changing as a result our
expectations would change so honestly
the early reaction like that wasn't a uh
wonderful memo to get from your CEO on a
Sunday night right so it kind of landed
uh a bit like a lead balloon uh
initially but we as a company is a
culture that really rallies we talk to
our teams the teams really rallied and I
think our performance since then yep has
been on an operating basis uh really
leading the pack and I think as we enter
2023 at least I feel we are well
prepared because we've been operating
based on the expectations of the real
world for a longer time than a lot of
other companies that you see are making
adjustments now and a lot of companies
to that point are making adjustments and
having to lay people off in significant
numbers yeah
um does your early action meant you are
going to avoid that I mean how do you
see that situation I certainly hope so
right we're we're not at this point
planning on any uh company-wide layoffs
Etc we it's a job of the CEO to
Performance manage people and parts of
the company all the time I'm always
going to be taking people out of you
know if there's a group or division
that's underperforming take people out
and then if I should reinvest those
folks or reinvest assets or marketing
monies that's part of the everyday job
of of a CEO so we will be making those
kinds of shifts but the Core Business uh
and the core Workforce Etc we think are
well balanced and well positioned for
the future I certainly hope it stays
that way but it is a dynamic environment
and and we're going to adjust pretty
quickly so very broadly the end of the
cheap money era you've talked about
inflation and Rising interest rates it's
obviously had this massive impact on
Tech valuations and Tech in general yeah
um how far do you think we are through
that adjustment
I I think that the
80 of the shock
is behind us and I think a lot of
companies you're seeing are making that
initial adjustment to get there uh I
personally think that
the markets generally are betting on a
softer fed
then I see
uh while commodity price inflation Etc
is definitely easing up we have a
Freight business uh that's involved in
transportation Transportation costs are
coming down pretty significantly I don't
see service inflation
as being transitory and I think that
it's making its way through the system
there's a there's a delayed effect in
terms of inflationary effects through
the supply chain then all all the way up
to Consumer and inflation moves slowly
through the system so we saw we were
surprised by it because we didn't see it
in the end product and so I think that
at least from my standpoint uh I think
the fed's gonna stay higher for longer
so for companies that are hoping for a
reprieve
or companies that are hoping hey this
will be a year things will be better
next year I just have to like make it
through this here I think they're going
to be disappointed so for those of us
who aren't sitting in Silicon Valley you
know under the surface how bad is the
pain and what are you seeing in terms of
the people you your suppliers people you
you do business with first of all I I
think it's a healthy shift that we're
going through right blue collar worker
uh paid generally has trailed GDP growth
Etc so I I think the shift that we're
going through in terms of Services
Industries uh Uber drivers couriers Etc
earnings uh moving up at at strong rates
I think that's a healthy shift for
economy and yes our economy is going to
have to make a make uh make an
adjustment but I think it it'll it'll be
a healthy adjustment one way or the
other uh your competitors had a rougher
ride your main competitor
um is there um is there anyone that you
particularly would fear in a
consolidation type situation coming into
your Market as a competitor I mean who
do you kind of terms of Rideshare of
coming in and buying left and actually
um doing something with it are there any
of the big Tech operators for people
that you particularly fear coming in and
taking you on honestly thoroughly I
don't spend too much time thinking about
it because it's a waste of time because
I'll get it wrong fine okay so let's
let's move on from that so I want to do
a quick uh quick round of questions and
then we'll get on to some other stuff
um when do you expect a meaningful
number of self-driving cars in your
Fleet
uh Define meaningful
uh 20 percent
oh wow uh
12 to 15 years 12 to 15 years
um my sex don't remind me 12 to 15 years
from now we will well
um but it keeps him it seems to push out
each time someone gets asked that
question but okay
um okay 15 to 20. I I will it be a U.S
recession
yes
okay uh will NASDAQ be higher or lower
at the end of the year
I don't care what is the biggest benefit
of having people back in the office
this the the reaction I think being back
in the office is incredibly important I
think that hybrid is the better way but
we've got to make that human connection
I missed it desperately so I'm trying to
force our team to come back uh and uh
some of them are happy about and some of
them are is there a drawback of having
people back in the office
sure convenience but you know some parts
of work aren't convenient that's why
it's called work okay and in terms of
and in terms of
um you get all of the benefit of
everyone meeting up at the water cooler
and chatting is there a downside to
people spending too much time
doing stuff that maybe is not so
relevant or is that just the positive of
being no I think it's part of being
human right it's it's uh I actually
think you you you had a nail on the head
which is zoom life is very transactional
right it's everything is By Appointment
you start at a certain time you end at a
certain time uh you can't have any
casual encounters like think about Davos
like imagine having Davos over Zoom
right it would be terrible yeah right
and and so they did this is yeah how was
it yes okay I don't think I should
comment here but we'll chat later yeah I
mean it was different so it's just
different the the casual encounters and
things get done faster it it I really
don't believe it should be the only way
so I've heard some CEOs are like five
days a week we're going back I don't
think going back is the right way but I
actually think the hybrid of the two you
get the energy in terms of being with
your team and then being remote for a
week totally fine right but then you you
need that connection and energy and kind
of the the quick interactions to to get
things done
um and just final thing
um are you still planning a uber
specifically designed car
we are working with various oems
to design cars for Rideshare okay we are
by far the biggest Rideshare partner out
there so I think we will be the first
partner for whom they design but I'd
expect them it's in their interest to
leverage whether whatever platforms that
they build across
a maximum volume of of rides but we're
definitely quite interested in in
talking oems about purpose-built
Vehicles I'd say more importantly for us
is actually about the EV transition
because EVS today uh the the uptake is
is happening but they are luxury item
the most popular
um uh item that the most popular car in
the in the Uber Fleet is a Prius right
affordable fuel efficient and so we need
more affordable uh electric vehicles out
there that is the headline conversation
that I'm having with oems purposeful
vehicles are great okay
um you touched on drivers is the
shortage over I mean there's been
obviously a lot of talk about the
tightness in the labor market of the
last few years which again was
inflationary you talked about the weight
is coming up at the bottom which is a
positive
um has that mitigated significantly are
you still struggling to find drivers or
is that over now the shortage isn't over
but the the momentum for us is moving in
the right direction we made a pretty
fundamental pivot in terms of our
company and our efforts to to be earner
first to be driver first to really focus
on the driver experience in terms of
onboarding improving customer service
driver earnings are excellent but even
giving them visibility for example to
earnings drivers in the US and many
other markets didn't know what
destination but the rider was going to
we now give them upfront destinations so
it's not just about pay it's about the
entire driver experience that's resulted
in uh driver turnover being down 20
percent
drivers are driving more so driver
engagement is up in the teens we added
about a million drivers so we're up to
actually million earners drivers and
Courier so we're up to 5 million earners
now on a global basis we're the world's
largest source of work not just gig work
and the momentum in terms of our earner
base is growing because the experience
is getting better and certainly The
Experience on Uber versus our
competition is starting to create some
space and inflation in terms of the
wages they need to earn is that still
very high
uh driver earnings versus uh driver
earnings last year significantly
increased I think that the increases
this year are going to mitigate someone
but I do think drivers are going to earn
more this coming year on average and to
what extent does that and again so this
is a little pet peeve of mine but to
what extent has that better visibility
for drivers hurt the consumer experience
in terms of cancellations and
um availability of of rides is that is
that affected the consumer appearance no
it it should it has and should improving
cancellations and that in the previous
World drivers who didn't see the
destination but then once they accepted
the trip saw a destination that they
didn't like they would cancel on you
right now what we do is we show them the
destination so that they already know
when they accept the trip so the
cancellation has got human traffic Etc
now sometimes the result is and the
experiences the spinner time which is
the amount of time you say I want to get
a driver and then when we match you up
with a driver that may take a little
longer and that's because the offer may
go to you it may go to me it may go to a
third driver uh before that driver
accepts but there's but they're
accepting with a lot more information we
think that's a win
um what would it mean there's been a lot
of talk around where the Uber drivers
employees or should be employees in
certain countries what impact would it
have on the business if you had to make
everyone an employee
oh it would be uh
terrible for the business would be
terrible for drivers I think the most
important thing to understand in terms
of drivers is you know I was in
Amsterdam uh before I came here 94 of
drivers in Amsterdam have said that they
don't want to be employees in the U.S
it's 80 percent of drivers don't want to
be employees if you want a job in this
economy almost anywhere you are you can
get a job
so there's a group of people who are
self-selecting into earnings
opportunities on Uber and or other gig
economy companies that want flexible and
and now increasingly very strong
earnings opportunities right on the U.S
average earnings per utilized that was
39 bucks an hour we are matching up the
flexibility of those earnings
opportunities increasingly now with
Benefits right uh in France for example
as a result of sectoral bargaining
representation by the drivers uh the
minimum amount that a driver can make on
a short trip is 7 Euro 65
in the UK they've got a vacation pay
pension benefits Etc we're having
discussions with States governments Etc
as to what those benefits can be
so that you now have an outcome
which is the flexibility to be able to
work where you want when you want
minimum earnings uh so it's quite a gray
area between employee and contractor
there's a lot of intermediate yeah I I
think it's a good you know it's a hybrid
right that's better than where we came
from
drivers want and what makes sense for
you you're very much in the equilibrium
very much
to fully answer your question in markets
where we have flipped over to employment
because we can operate Uber in an
employment model about two-thirds of
drivers essentially lose the opportunity
to work on the platform that's a big
number that would be a tragedy when
you're talking about five million
earners on the platform right is there
ever going to be I mean a lot of the a
lot of companies have this situation
where there's the American dream if you
start on the shop floor and you end up
as the CEO is there ever going to be a
situation with Uber drivers where that
career progression inside the company is
possible or is it always going to be
drivers and the rest yeah that situation
is now so so one is uh you should keep
in mind that drivers the longer drivers
drive the more money they make because
they understand the system they
understand when should I drive when
should I not drive where should I go Etc
and as they learn the system they just
earn more it's a it's a natural learning
process the map drivers make is directly
related to their utilization on the
platform and the utilization on the
platform gets better and better as you
understand the platform so that's number
one second for us is drivers the most
loyal drivers the best drivers we now
provide them uh free college education
um uh through University of Phoenix they
can get either a degree for themselves
or for a family member really cool
program then I'm a big fan of we've now
built a program where we got these
centers of excellence or green light
hubs that essentially are customer
service centers for Riders and drivers
we hire drivers
to then become customer service reps Etc
if they do want a full-time job
so that's a ladder that that moves up to
customer service Etc we then take the
best of our green light agents customer
service uh Hub agents uh and we have
classes now where we teach them how to
code
we have had classes where we teach them
how to be sales people to go and sell to
restaurants for ubereats so we're
creating our own paths up where if you
want to stay a driver you can make more
and you have certain benefits and you
have educational benefits either for
your family or you can enter the Uber
system in a full-time manner if that's
something that's really interesting so
you're not stuck as a driver there is a
progression that's really yeah I mean
you've got to build that progression I
think I think companies talk about it we
try to do it it's great
um you've been in Ukraine just before
coming here for a couple of days
um
can you just quickly talk a little bit
about
um what you're doing on the ground and
and also what have you learned that you
want to sort of put in place as you're
planning for other places around the
world where disasters happen where you
are basically part of the critical
infrastructure of of the transportation
so can you just give us a quick
absolutely absolutely it was great being
on the ground with the team uh we we've
been operating Ukraine Ukraine since
2016 we've got about 25
000 drivers in in Ukraine and we first
started with using our transportation
services to get refugees to safety get
them to the border and Poland now we're
focused on uh helping doctors get to
hospitals helping teachers get to
schools I met some of those doctors I
met some of those teachers you know the
transportation that we take for granted
here they can't take for granted when
they're Rockets attacks when there are
power outages Etc the the the
availability mass transit is is quite
spotty we then built a really
interesting program with the un uh
getting food and also uh items for
winter shelter uh blankets Etc where we
built a private label version of
essentially the Uber fulfillment
infrastructure you don't want to use big
trucks marked Vans Etc to get these
supplies out to ngos that then get to
get them to uh to real people in in need
who've been displaced so we essentially
have a private label Uber right where
they can hail an Uber it's a private
vehicle comes in picks up the stuff or a
private truck picks up stuff gets them
to the NGO they get them out to uh folks
who've been displaced again I got to see
one of those ngos at work very tech
savvy very entrepreneurial incredibly
organized so for me it was really
encouraging to see the work on the
ground we work with the ministry of
culture to provide transportation to
take works of art and get them to uh
places of safety get them restored so
that we can retain these incredibly
important pieces of art and culture in
Ukraine as well so for me seeing on the
ground and most importantly
supporting the team letting them know
that I'm with them and and also making
sure that I send the message to Uber
employees and hopefully broaders that
we've got to stay with Ukraine you know
I I went to bucha uh where there are
these where where these terrible
atrocities happen you know when you see
the pit
in which these
victims were buried not buried I mean
throw it into it just it just uh breaks
your heart
uh and I think we're talking about it
here which is great is that we've got to
stand behind Ukraine no one knows when
this war is going to end uh and and and
we've got to stay behind Ukraine for as
long as it takes Uber certainly intenses
and what have you learned in terms of
you know in other countries when you
know unexpected things happen
particularly quickly in terms of plans
that can click into place to facilitate
some of these these movement the the
the really interesting
factor in terms of uber and what makes
it interesting is that it's so
unpredictable right uh every single City
in which we operate is different every
single circumstance is different so we
don't have a Playbook yeah the Playbook
is how can we help right and so with
Ukraine it literally started with
refugees and then it just organically
went to places that we can help I'm
sitting down with a ton of partner
organizations and it's just how can we
help how can we do more Ubers Uber is
unique in that we're a technology
company we've got a big scope we're in
over 70 countries but we're hyper hyper
local so the Playbook is the teams
working with government officials and
then just being entrepreneurial in
general and trying to help in every
single City in which we operate
brilliant thank you
um
I got an email yesterday from weft
saying that uh Nadella who was here
actually earlier in the week
um was talking about the AI golden age
and that it's good for Humanity uh do
you agree with that
uh yes there will be volatility but long
term it'll be good for Humanity and what
does it mean for your business
it we use you know it's not the kind of
the chat GPT AI et cetera but we use
machine learning extensively in our
business in terms of uh how we deal with
real world situations if you look at
Uber uh every the pricing routing Etc is
incredibly Dynamic and our system has to
on a real time basis adjust to
everything happening locally there is no
kind of global model Etc but we do have
these AI models that essentially are
learning behaviors on a local basis so
if you look at a pricing Algos matching
Algos routing algorithms fraud
algorithms Etc all of it is powered by
larger learning models that continue to
get better and better and better so it's
a pretty practical use of AI but it is
um it's it's an everything that we do
okay and when you answered the original
question you you had to think a little
bit uh it happens sometimes yeah but
what I I it wasn't a criticism it was um
what are the downsides I mean you
obviously you know there's obviously a
balance in there I mean what do you see
as the risk do you know technology yeah
yeah I think the downsides are that well
I guess short-term downsides or pain
could be that there will be displacement
right so if you think about chat gbt you
can imagine
uh restaurant menu descriptions
restaurant descriptions being written uh
by AI the copy in terms of email and
Communications that we send to our
customers being written by Ai and being
um personalized on a one-to-one basis
the the use cases are pretty powerful
right now when we send in email uh to
you thanking you for uh being an Uber
customer you know it's a standard email
yep it will be an email to you that will
be personalized Etc that standard email
is written by person right right so the
the applications are going to uh
initially put some people out of jobs
yep but what happens in our economy
always on a long-term basis then those
people find other use cases or else you
may go from a copywriter to a chat gbt
uh user who is responsible for the
nature and the the feel of these uh
emails that ultimately are written by
Chachi PT Etc so that adjustment period
can be difficult can be scary Etc but I
think the end state is going to be a
good one right uh we have time for oh
wow okay
in the front
questions was my my last word which I
didn't get to but go for it um thank you
Gerald
um Dara you came into Uber in a fairly
tumultuous public cultural
situation my curiosity to you is as you
looked at the culture of uber what were
the behaviors that you wanted to retain
what were the ones that you wanted to
change and I'm particularly interested
in your executive team and and how you
leverage that executive team to change
the culture of uber yeah absolutely it's
a great question
um the the culture that I want to retain
at Uber the time was this is incredible
entrepreneurial energy
Innovative you know go get them culture
uh that was always thinking about what's
the newest best way of operating it's
incredible rally culture it's like let's
go we're not going to wait for a second
Etc that that culture we've kept the
majority of that culture and that
culture is like Second To None I love it
it is so much fun because people really
rally at the company
um that that culture was used to be the
ultimate disrupter right in terms of
disrupting the transportation system Etc
at some point the disrupter became an
incumbent
and where the company failed was to
understand
the responsibilities that come with
incumbency
and if you're acting like a disruptor
but you're really an incumbent you kind
of look like a jerk right and and you're
not taking a response to be seriously
Etc I don't think it's because there's
anyone who is bad there
but things were moving so quickly that
there wasn't the time to kind of reflect
and say well what are responsibilities
so the changes that I made in terms of
management actually were uh on the
executive team that was more responsible
for some of these factors that brought a
new CFO uh Nelson Che I brought in a new
general counsel new head of HR Etc and
then at the same time the operating
leads of the company who were kind of
doing the real work in terms of
operations you know the head of Mobility
operation operations delivery operations
uh our head of uh comms and and
marketing Jill hazelblaker who's here
like these were stars who were there uh
who were at Uber before me and hopefully
will be an Uber after me so I think what
I'm trying to achieve with Uber is a
combination of the newest and the old
which is keep that entrepreneurial
energy and Edge uh and the ability to
move incredibly fast but but recognize
the enormous responsibility that we have
and the dialogue that you know can slow
us down which we're an impatient group
but is very very necessary to make sure
that ultimately when we act we're acting
with the right intent and the output is
that we're doing the right thing as a
company
there's another I'll go there there and
then there
so Uber has committed to be Net Zero by
2040. can you get there earlier uh we
can in certain places right so we have
committed to be Net Zero by 2030 in the
U.S Canada and Europe uh in London for
example the target's 2025. uh and and we
are making progress for example
California now uh were at about 10
kilometer miles being EVS which is
pretty awesome lots of Teslas in
California uh in Europe it's about eight
percent kilometer uh miles and about
five times the the percentage of
generally what you see kilometer miles
in Europe and I think that shifting the
Uber driver over to driving EV is so
much more impactful than the average
driver because the Uber driver is
driving five to six to seven times you
know the number of miles and the average
drivers so this is a very very targeted
group of people that we should switch
over to EV as soon as possible the
biggest blocker I talked about are
affordable EVs and also try charging
infrastructure within cities most cities
are putting charging infrastructure in
the center cities that's where wealthy
people tend to live but they're not
putting EV infrastructure where many of
our drivers live and many of our drivers
need it which is in some of the
outskirts and other neighboring areas of
the city we are working with cities to
give them the data to provide them with
hey here are the different areas where
you should be putting charging
infrastructure and we're working both
with private and public to help
shape the plans in terms of charging
infrastructure it's going in the right
direction but but it's going to take a
lot of effort from a lot of people who
get there
um
gentlemen
um yes I'm Philippe Monier I represent
the Swiss technology providers
specialize in automotive name way Ray
you said before that you are talking to
OEM in order to have customized a car
especially for you ride sharing services
if it is not secret can you share to
which OEM you're talking on which speed
thick
characteristic those car will have I
will give the very unsanisary act answer
of it is Secret
I'm sorry
um
uh the characteristics for
um
uh for Rod sharing one is the passenger
area uh sometimes passengers facing each
other I do think that top speeds for
example top speeds that many cars have
are not necessary for City Driving
that's associated with Rideshare we're
also talking about purpose build
vehicles for delivery right you can
imagine smaller Vehicles two wheelers
three wheelers that have trunk space
that that can get through traffic easier
and have a much smaller footprint both
in terms of environmental but also
traffic footprint than let's say a car
to go and deliver groceries so those are
the various areas we're looking at so
you're likely to be more of a black cab
facing each other model is that that's
certainly a model that we're looking at
but it part of it is just what are the
capabilities right you don't you're not
going to have in many cities quite as
much highway driving than you do in the
US Etc that can reduce the specs and if
you reduce the specs you can reduce the
ultimate cost final question and I know
we don't we don't agree but the
gentleman here
um us it will take some time for to have
more electric cars would you consider to
have an option allow the customer who
cannot take electric car and then just
like would you like to tip or would you
like to offset your carbon footprint
after they take the journey so I think
uh if you understand your question we
have the option for Riders now to take
Uber green and to specifically request
electric cars and what we've seen from
customers is that
customers generally don't want to pay a
premium in terms of dollars for an
electric car but they are willing to pay
a premium in terms of time so if the
average uh time to get a ride is four
minutes in the market five minutes in
Market there's a segment of customers
who will wait 10 minutes to get uh to
get an electric car
customers tip better for electric cars
it just kind of works that way uh which
is pretty cool we are looking at offsets
but honestly we're spending more time
just changing over the fleet right so
offsets is certainly a characteristic
we'll look at but I think just spending
the energy on changing over the fleet is
the highest impact activity of the day
brilliant Darth thank you so much for
your time I know you've got to get to
another meeting so thank you thank you
very much